one problem 161 the positive integer n
is divisible by 25 if the square root of
n is greater than 25 the square root of
n is greater than 25 which of the
following could be the value of n
divided by 25 so what could be a valid
value for n divided by 25 let's see if
we can manipulate this a little bit if
we square both sides we get n right the
square root the square of the square
root of n is n is greater than 625 and
then if we divide both sides by 25 we
get n over 25 is greater than 25 so this
value that they a valid value for n over
25 has to be greater than 25 if we look
at all the choices there's only one
value that's greater than 25 and that's
e 26 problem 162 looks like they want to
make sure we know how to deal with
fractions one over one plus one over two
plus one-third let's just drive through
this map that equals one over one plus
one over C two is the same thing as
three there no sorry it's six thirds
right six thirds plus one third is 7/3
so this is equal to one over one plus
one over seven thirty the same thing as
three sevenths and sin so that's equal
to one over seven seven s plus three
seven so it's ten sevenths which is
equal to 7 over 10 which is choice B
switch colors 163 163 a fruit salad
mixture consists of apples peaches and
grapes in the ratio so the apples two
peaches two grapes is equal to six two
five two two respectively by weight if
39 pounds of the mixture is prepared
the mixture includes how many more
pounds of apples and grapes so they want
it we want they want to figure out the
apples - the grapes okay so they tell us
that the apples plus the peaches plus
the grapes is equal to 39 pounds when
you're dealing with the ratios it's
useful to say well each of these is
going to be equal to I guess you'd call
it their ratio number times some number
right let's say that apples let me
explain what I'm saying let's just say
that apples are equal to 6 times some
number X right
well if apples are equal to 6 times some
number X then peaches are going to be
equal to 5 times that number X right
because the ratio of the apples to the
peaches is 6 to 5 all right so if you
did 6x over 5x you get 6 to 5 and by the
same logic then the grapes would be 2
times that same number X and all the
ratios would work out so we can
substitute all of these back into that
equation and you get 6x plus 5x plus 2x
is equal to 39 6 plus 5 is 11 plus 2
well actually I have a phone call that I
was expecting so let me continue this in
the next video